it is not just a border state problem
governor ron desantis says illegal
immigrants are flocking
to florida all the way from the southern
border listen
and they say that almost 70 percent of
everybody that they have interdicted
said their ultimate destination was the
state of florida
so if you think that having a wide open
border
thousand miles 15 however far was away
it doesn't affect here you're wrong
florida congresswoman cat cammic just
returned from the border saw the crisis
firsthand she joins me live to tell us
all about it congresswoman thanks as
always for being here
how worried are you about governor
desantis warning
well good morning to you both and uh
yeah i am
terrified this is something that keeps
me up at night and should keep every
american up at night because
in the face of this border crisis every
single town in america
is a border town let me repeat that
every town
in america is a border town and we know
that not just from
the illegals that have been apprehended
and then released into our communities
but the narcotics if you look at the
narcotics that have been
confiscated at the border it's enough to
kill every man woman and child in the
state of florida
nine times over just this year and
that's just fentanyl
this is a crisis of epic proportions and
you know when you look at what's
happening
the governor hit right on it 70 of those
talked to
that are being apprehended and released
back into the united states
they are destined for florida in my
district alone i just returned from the
border with
six sheriffs from our area and they are
already seeing
people being placed they're seeing an
increase in crime
from the actions of this administration
the overdoses that are taking place you
know we lost 93 000 americans last year
to overdoses
that number is going to skyrocket and
we're already seeing that
and when you think about this this byte
administration has
basically said if you're from any other
country which we have about 140
different nationalities coming through
our southwest border
if you're from any other nationality
except for cuba come on over
because when they were very clear my
myercus secretary marcus was very clear
about do not come here if you're from
cuba but yet if you're from anywhere
else
come through the southwest border we're
open for business it's like the
it's like a welcoming party truly the
most expensive
welcoming party i have ever seen and i'm
telling you i
witnessed it firsthand right standing
there on the banks of the river
and and it's just it's heartbreaking you
cannot begin to
protect your hometowns if we can't
defend
the homeland and that starts with border
security if you had any question
that this was about the votes i think
that point that you just made
cuba versus every place else because
cuban americans by and large
vote republicans it does appear the feds
that are currently in charge
do not want those individuals in the
country because of their voting habits
got to leave it there congressman you
gave a very robust answer to my first
question
that's all the time we have
congresswoman cat cam we appreciate your
time as always
thank you thank you so much have a good
one